ring the banks I mean like these message
welcome to the is the mic alright thanks
for coming oh we're already energized
after lunch anyway so I gonna talk about
incentivizing exploration it's about the
line of work joint with Shia by citizens
to you so our motivation comes from
recommender systems and there is a whole
bunch of them out there I mean they can
tell us which movie to watch where it's
dying which doctor to see and so forth
and also some of our stuff is relevant
to its medical trials and I'll talk
about that connection in the end of the
talk ok so let's make it slightly more
concrete so we're looking at recommender
system and the you know the following
scenario a user shows up he wants to
choose a product among some alternatives
then the user receives the
recommendation and maybe some extra
feedback like ratings or something then
he chooses a product and hopefully also
leave the feedback and leaves ok so one
thing to notice here is that there can
be
datian can is usually based on the
feedback from the users that that came
before and the feedback will be will be
used to improve recommendations in the
future so in other words each user has
this dual role being both a consumer and
the producer of them of information okay
so so in the interest of a common good
the population of users should balance
exploration and exploitation and you
know one way to achieve that is to
coordinate using the recommendations of
the system and of course you know if
we've only cared about common good they
would all follow the recommendations
well then of course the users are
actually self-interested agents and so
they are not very altruistic and instead
they will try to do what is best for
them based on the information that they
have and maybe the initial biases that
they might have so okay and that may you
know this kind of social behavior it may
really stand in the way of exploration I
mean for a simple example what if users
are initially slightly biased against
one of their alternatives and it may
just happen that that alternative will
be completely unexplored or you know not
explore it to the sufficient extent so
it's kind of bad so the kind of big
question here is how to incentivize
self-interested agents to explore okay
so let's make it slightly more concrete
I mean we'd like to incentivize agents
to try out actions that seem suboptimal
either because of the agents biases or
because of the current information in
the system and and you know even if the
system currently knows that this does
not seem like the best actually you know
you know a bandit algorithm would still
elect you explore it a little bit right
okay there is a lot of prior work on
like you know trying to do that in
practice in several different ways I
mean one could offer payments to
potential patients to participate in a
medical trial for example or one could
offer sort of you know merit badges
you know a promise of a higher social
status to people who live high quality
reviews on something that needs to be
reviewed or there may be hope to just
freeride on people's desire to
experiment I mean some people just like
experiment but you know all of that is
good you know it has its place but there
are some issues with it I mean one is
the like it's not always possible I mean
you may not have enough money to pay to
enough patients for example and the
other thing is all of that is prone to
selection bias because you know you'll
end up seeing you know more patients
that are poor or you know you'll get
reviews from these weird bunch of people
who appreciates merit badges or you know
you'll get you know you'll see lots of
people who like risks and so forth so
you know it's not necessarily that the
population that you're going to see that
way is going to represent the actual
population I mean there are ways to kind
of mitigate this and stuff but here we
try to explore an alternative approach
so we'd like to use information
asymmetry that is the fact that they
algorithm in general knows more than any
given agent in order to create a certain
field intrinsic incentives in other
words we want the agent to kind of
follow our recommendation just because
we recommended it to you okay so that's
kind of a high-level go now it's a good
time to lay out a basic model and I mean
it's already I mean although it's kind
of simple it's already kind of
challenging actually quite a bit
challenging and I'll talk about a few
extensions in the end of the talk so
it's basically
a bandit problem with an extra
constraint because of incentives so we
have K actions T rounds t say it is
known in advance in each round the new
agent arrives the algorithm recommends
an action and maybe some extra
information the agent chooses an action
and reports the reward and it's like you
know as usual it manages let's assume
everything is bounded and is running
through okay then let's assume iid the
words in other words the distribution of
a reward depends only on the chosen
action not on the round the mean rewards
are not known but we have a bayesian
prior on every sign and let's assume
it's a common prior meaning like you
know everybody has the same prior about
the all agents and the algorithm okay so
let's say the objective of the algorithm
is social welfare in other words the
cumulative reward okay so if all agents
just follow the recommendations it is
precisely a bandit problem which is well
understood and stuff okay but now we
have you know selfish agents so we need
to account for their incentives and so
we need to ensure that following the
recommendation is in their best interest
so okay let's let's express that the
precise so we say that the
recommendation algorithm is better than
incentive compatible if you know given
the fact that we receive that the
recommendation in reality is a
particular action a one can do a
Bayesian
sir what can take a conditional
expectation and realize that actually
the best thing is to follow that action
and we want that to hold for all actions
and all rounds so if an algorithm
satisfies that we call it better
incentive compatible so that's the
constraint that we want and so the goal
is to design B I see by net algorithms
with good performance and one particular
thing we could ask is well can be AC
bandit algorithms perform as well in
some sense as the best bandit
rhythms BAC or not or you know how much
do we need to lose okay so let me kind
of discuss if you think so I mean
clearly the algorithm wants to balance
explore and exploit but actually we have
this three way thread of here between
explore exploit and and incentives so
you know the algorithm may want to
choose above two more arms for the sake
of getting more information but the
agents don't want that you know each
agent just wants to the bail wants to do
the the best thing and in particular it
like the agent will choose the best
thing based on what she knows which is
three things at the common prior at the
recommendation algorithm itself and the
algorithms recommendation and maybe some
extra information if any okay so in
particular we assume that the agent does
not see the entire feedback from the
past instead it only sees whatever the
algorithm chooses to reveal this is kind
of an important point because like if
all information is revealed it really
doesn't work because then basically the
only thing that we could convince the
agent to do is to take the you know
exploit action and we know that
exploitation only is not a good time in
particular like it's easy it's easy to
see that there are problem instances in
which if we do it this way then we can
then the algorithm can only pick this
one arm that seems best according to the
prior and this may really not be the
right arm in the in the realization okay
so we see that the algorithm needs to
reveal all less than it actually knows
well how much does it need to reveal so
it turns out one can sort of do a
revelation argument to show that like it
surprises to reveal only their commanded
arm and no extra information in other
words if there is like anything we could
do very billion more information we can
also do the same thing if we only reveal
the
the recommended arm so so so now kind of
without loss of generality I'm going to
assume that the only thing revealed is
the recommended arm okay so what's the
general approach here is that we're
going to try to hide a little
exploration in a lot of exploitation and
like why can I possibly work well you
see each agent knows that he gets
exploitation choice with high
probability and exploration with low
probability and he doesn't know which
right but kind of on a balance we can
you know tune the probabilities so that
he still falls he still falls
recommendation because he knows that you
know most likely it was exploitation now
it kind of explains you know why it can
possibly work but it's very far from
saying you know it will work or it will
work optimally right
so okay now it's it's a place to mention
some related work so okay of course it
it relates to a bunch of all convened
it's most notably on venues with AD
rewards with without a prior it's kind
of the most fundamental results and also
to some stuff on the best arm prediction
and also to some to some other lines of
work which involves kind of combination
of Benny's food incentives but all of
that work is kind of technically very
different on kind of very different
topics and there is some real some kind
of closely related work in economics so
they're kind of initial paper which
asked this question was won by Kramer
monster and Perry and they looked at
essentially the same model but only with
two arms and deterministic rewards and
they do kind of they're mainly result is
the Bayesian optimal algorithm for
deterministic rewards and they have on
there a preliminary results for the IAD
rewards also there is a really nice
paper by a first year at all which looks
at a closely related problem but kind of
different
the kind of same problem but the
payments are allowed and agents observed
the entire past and the point is to
achieve optimal trade-off between the
payment and you know and utility I mean
how much you pay to the agents how much
rigidity you get so it's kind of related
but kind of in flavor it's very
different and also there are some
connections to some high profile work in
economics say something called a
Bayesian reservation it essentially
describes a single round of our model
well a simple round of a generalization
of our model and the work on strategic
experimentation it's kind of similar
setting where multiple agents are doing
the learning but there is no principal I
mean there is no recommender ok so
that's that now let me talk a little bit
about the main result and some of the
key ideas and I'll mention some other
results later on so first I mean how do
you measure performance let's not beat
you original here we'll talk about
regret all right so we can I define the
expected total reward of the algorithm
we can define well something that we
call ex post regret which is kind of a
kind of the usual regret like for a
given problem instance and then we can
talk about Bayesian regret which is
expectation of ex post regret over the
prior right so our main result is is
about Bayesian regret and I mean kind of
in general we can ask an out can be IC
banette algorithms achieve optimal
regret right and in its absence the
answer is yes
so the main result is a blackbox
reduction so I can take any bandit
algorithm that you like and we and we
can convert it into a BAC Bennett
algorithm with similar performance in
the sense that it's Bayesian regret is
blown up only by a constant factor
and the question factor can depend on
the prior but it's only constant so you
know if that was optimal it's still
optimal up to a constant I mean it
depends on the prior not on the time
horizon that's the point
also one could look at the version of a
bandit algorithm which also outputs a
prediction I mean usually it's a
prediction of which arm is the best arm
but it could be prediction of something
else and we also get that kind of
reaction I mean our new algorithm also
outputs predictions and essentially what
happens is that the learning rate I mean
you know the speed of learning decreases
by a constant factor
well the constant factor so this result
is nice in the sense that it's modular I
mean like we can take an existing system
and we threat of inject incentives into
that system and kind of modular design
is a good way and sometimes you know the
only feasible way to design complicated
systems the other thing to notice is
that the setup can incorporate auxiliary
information such as a prior cause you
know we can take an algorithm that you
know he uses that information and the
alka the the the original algorithm can
also incorporate maybe some preferences
over which arms should be you know
favorite or throttled in exploration and
kind of a reduction a base that you
finally like I said the prediction does
not have to be the best arm I mean we
could be interested about which arms are
low performing and then we may hope to
like prune them away using regulation or
some time so for all we care about the
algorithm here could be predicting the
worst arm and it still works ok let me
say a few words about how this thing
works and kind of the basic question to
answers like how can you possibly hope
to sample the other arm I mean you know
say if arm
one is favored by the prior there are
only two arms how can we possibly you
know convince the agent to try arm - all
right so like I said like I said before
the idea is to hide exploration in a
large pool of exploitation so here's
what I mean for the first couple of
rounds will play arm one because that's
kind of the only thing we can do then we
pick up kind of exploit our arms through
a posterior update I mean we do better
an update we arrive at the posterior and
we choose the best arm according to the
posterior we call it the exploit arm now
in the remainder we use the exploit or a
mean every round except one one round
chosen uniformly at random and in that
that kind of Explorer
round we recommend arm - and you know
key and there are the parameters here so
what is going on here I mean the first
thing if we collect enough samples of
arm one then we make sure that it's
possible for arm two to be the exploit
arm like an out there is a nonzero
probability that it could have and then
when an agent is recommended arm to it
doesn't know why it could because its
exploration or it could be because arm
two is now the exploit arm so good and
then we kind of use the fact that that
exploration happens with a low
probability and then we can rig it so
that the agent one actually wants to
follow its follow key mediation because
you know he knows that exploitation was
way more likely and it kind of over ways
the the downside of of exploration so so
that kind of explained how we can
possibly try one arm but okay now we can
now we need to turn it into a good
algorithm so the actual black box
reduction I mean let me present it just
for your two arms it consists of two
phases the two stages the sampling stage
in the simulation stage the sampling
stage is just like we need to sample
each arm and it precedes essentially as
a as I said before now we have a
simulation stage where we actually
simulate the algorithm and it precedes
in phases such that in each phase which
we call the original algorithm once so
here here's how it goes in the beginning
of each phase we compute I mean we do
the Bayesian update we compute the
exploit arm so we choose exploit arm and
every round except one and that one
round shows the uniformly at random and
in that one round we make a call to the
original algorithm and we feedback the
word I mean that's it right and again if
we collect enough when you show samples
then like we we can ensure that any arm
could be the exploit arm here so when
the agent receives the recommendation
forum - it doesn't know why and then we
make the probability of calling the
algorithm a low enough so that the agent
is incentivized to follow recommendation
and I mean the proof needs to go through
some technicalities but that's
essentially yet and awesome so that's it
for two arms and I to analyze
performance now it's kind of kind of
easy the main thing to observe is that
they expected base and reward of the
exploit arm is at least as good as that
as that of the algorithm just by
definition of the exploit arm I mean
which wasn't the best we could and the
algorithm and the algorithm itself could
be exploring for all men now so that
just means we kind of track the rewards
of the algorithm except the learning
speed of the algorithm is delay it cuz
we're calling it on the ones in every
phase and so that kind of easily leads
to to a bond and regret okay likewise if
an algorithm if the original algorithm
out
the prediction in each round then the
this new algorithm just outputs the same
prediction in all rounds of the next
phase and that's it the you know three
really the distribution of the
prediction Insurance II is distributed
exactly the prediction of the original
algorithm so it just means that the
learning is slowed down by a constant
factor okay there are a bunch of more
technicalities to kind of extend it to K
arms but I'm going to skip in the
interest of time because I wanna I want
to mention a few other things okay if I
had a choice of what among among
algorithm say that you could potentially
use just given the description when she
preferred pure exploration that wouldn't
stuff
you mean algorithms that optimize pure
explore well it depends it depends what
you want I mean if you want to have a
good wage and regret you will probably
start with an algorithm will with a good
wage and regret if you only care about
the quality of production then you
wouldn't care about variant regret okay
so it's kind of easy to see that the
problem like there are some priors for
which the problem is completely hopeless
for example you know if the prior is
such that they mean reward the farm one
and the difference between the two
rewards are independent then you know
initially we can only try arm one and no
matter how many samples of arm one we
have we cannot possibly convince any
agent to try arm two curves you know it
doesn't give us any information about
the difference okay so so in this case
the algorithm is doomed to always try
arm one okay so it means we need to make
some assumptions to make it work and our
assumption is as follows so essentially
if we take enough samples of arm one
rm2 can become exploit arm so the blue
thing just says that arm to arm - that's
become the exploit arm after case
samples of arm one and this happens with
you know and nonzero probability so in
some sense it's kind of a fighting
chance assumption I mean I to give the
algorithm of fighting chance and we show
it's necessary
I mean it's necessary for any BAC
algorithm to in order to try arm to and
and it is sufficient for the blackbox
reduction for the case of Jones and for
more than two arms who have a similar
condition we cannot prove it's necessary
but this condition includes a nice case
of you know initial case of independent
priors okay so in the remainder let me
mention a few other results so well okay
I guess it's kind of shifting gears at
the moment so I also have another result
obtaining good you know exposed regret
meaning good regret for any given
readers at any any given realization of
the prior and essentially it is the best
I mean you know optical stand factor
it's the optimal regret both for whether
you know instant dependence sense and in
the worst case and but we have this walk
t term with the constant that depends on
the prior and it could get a really
large depending on the prior so one way
to think about it it is the price that
we pay for incentive computability it's
in this which is in this theorem
essentially this term is about like how
difficult it is to convince an agent to
try arm to which essentially is about
how concentrated is the prior on the
goodness of arm one if it's if you know
if the prior says that okay arm one is
really going to be my
better than okay only many many rounds
to convince but it's good it's kind of
inevitable at least intuitively okay
another result
oh yeah and in some sense kind of
essentially resolves this problem for a
constant number of arms okay
but another result is that the black box
reduction actually works essentially in
the same way in a much more general
setting when the algorithm observe
observes a context it could be like a
customer profile at Amazon then you know
the algorithm recommends an arm or make
a prediction then the agent chooses the
arm and reports forward and maybe extra
feedback and then the distribution of
the of the reward and the feedback
depends not only on the arm but also on
the context so it's kind of contextual
bandits would extra feedback so directly
the extra feedback could be you know I'd
also a restaurant and I live not just
kind of my overall satisfaction score
with the meal but a detailed review of a
video right and on the economic side
this kind of allows agents to be a
little different from one another on the
machine learning inside that essentially
allows to kind of plug in three major
lines of work and bandits one on
contextual bandits one on bandits with
like more feedback than just shows an
arm and one on Bendis with a
reoccurrence and it's come and the
reduction is completely oblivious to the
algorithm so you know you can take our
favorite algorithm okay and the final
thing that I wanted to mention is a
slightly more complicated setup where in
each round instead of a single agent
showing up we have like a batch of
agents that show up and play a game
so like one age
actions could impact other agents
actions and you know it could be a game
with the noisy payoffs but it has to be
the same game in every round right so so
agents show up the algorithm recommends
an action to each agent so it's like
think of the driving directions on ways
you know every morning the bunch of
people you know or show up and need to
drive to work I need to choose their
driving route and you know my choice
overall can impact other people because
of congestion and then you know the ways
can can recommend the routes and
convince people to do something socially
optimal that kind of stuff so more
formally in each round the algorithm
chooses a distribution over the action
profiles and the solution concept is
something called Bayesian correlated
equilibrium I won't go into the details
of that and the point is that you know
given that my recommendation is this
particular action and I need to be
incentivized to follow I mean in
expectation over everything that I know
I need to be incentivized to follow that
that recommendation so in this
formulation things get kind of very
technical very fast and so I'll only
mention a few things that are kind of a
few high-level things that make it
different one is that you know before we
used to have a condition that grantee
does that all actions can be explored by
v.i.c algorithm now it's no longer the
case and we really need to think very
carefully which action profiles can be
explored and how to actually explore all
of them and then okay say we explore it
all we all we possibly can and we have
all that information how do we use that
information meaning like what is the
best equilibrium achievable with that
information and how to converge on that
equilibrium so kind of these are the
these sort of high-level things to worry
about and in this model I'm sort of and
it was a end of deliver on that okay so
enough for the technical part I want to
discuss one go in and present a few open
problems so I hope I have a few mins to
do that
so a thing that I want to discuss is a
is a potential connection to medical
trials so you see the basic design of
medical trial is okay you have you know
a base treatment or as opposed to a new
drug or maybe like a placebo or a new
drug and you know the patients are
blindly and randomly assigned into one
of the treatments right but some you
know adaptive designs are studied and
used me like you know the algorithm
could be the trial could be adaptive
there could be more arms there could be
context and so forth
so so it's actually not a crazy thing to
do as evidenced by the talk on Monday
morning by don't bury and so okay and in
fact the medical trials were one of the
original motivations for bandits okay
but let's but I mean one you should here
is the patients incentives I mean why
would the patient participate in this
trial you know why would I subject
myself to this new unknown drug right
and I mean it's especially major so it
seems like it seems like a major
obstacle and it seemed especially so for
you know widespread diseases and cheap
drugs when you know it's not difficult
to find patients with a flu it's not
difficult you know it's okay for them
for their treatments and you know in
principle every time I take a poop
referent for a headache I could be
contributing data to science but somehow
it's not happening and it seems one big
reason it's not happening is that
incentives somehow are not aligned in
the right way so
so one way to one you know highly
idealized the way to think about it is
to think of working of a medical trial
as a recommendation algorithm I mean you
know I show up when the trial tells me
okay I take this drug and somehow I
should through you know I should believe
that this isn't my best interest to
follow that recommendation so
conveniently it is okay in the practice
of medical trials and not to reveal to
the patient's any information about the
current state of the medical trial which
kind of matches our setting we don't
want to reveal anything that we don't
have to review and actually it is very
important to prevent selection biases in
the inter medical trials like they the
best practices guide is very very clear
on that and also kind of extension to
contacts and extra feedback is kind of
appropriate here of course you know the
patients are different they come with
different contacts and we can get a lot
more extra information than just a you
know overall success of the treatment so
it seems kind of a you know highly
idealized maybe you know one idealized
way to you know attack this issue okay
open questions there are there is a
whole bunch open questions one bunch is
a sort of with ml flavor I mean you know
in the in the basic in the basic model
what is the optimal dependence on the
prior and we really don't know what is
the dependence of the number of actions
I mean our current algorithm has
exponential dependence and it's not
clear if one can do any better
there could be all over bound for all I
know
what if action space has some known
structure like linear convex lifts for
not can we use that and make it
compatible and you know some exploration
happens anyway because people just like
to explore so how can we take advantage
of that
and then a few more questions were the
sort of economics or more games there is
a flavor I mean we'd like to have
algorithms that are detailed free in the
sense that you know the algorithm needs
to know very little or like really
nothing about the prior and we have a
result in that direction and would like
to do more and in particular maybe it's
possible to like not assume that we know
stuff but to elicit that but you know in
that case we need to be careful to make
sure that you know agents are not
incentivized to lie okay
and the other thing is so in the BAC
blended game that I just talked about in
the previous slide it may be possible to
achieve big improvements both in regret
and in the running time if the game has
a 16-3 presentation I mean if if you
know it's not just a crazily
crazily beacon complicated game matrix
which which would not now but say we
know it has like you know everything is
linearly dependent on a single parameter
it should be easier but you know it's
not quite clear how to how to use that
and the last point I wanted to mention
is that I mean we assume that we only
reveal the recommended arm and when you
we could do it in theory if we know the
prior by application of relation
principle and it was very convenient but
in practice we may be required to reveal
more information I mean we may you know
know like if it if we don't need to
reveal then we maybe won't reveal but
what if we require it to do that I mean
what have you know you know Amazon
Amazon cannot just say by this you know
Amazon needs to provide something like a
rating then it becomes kind of more
complicated in several ways I mean one
is it's not even clear how to model this
in a way that applies to many things at
once because what can and what must be
review may be very
depending on the application and you
know it's very nice to have like an
approach deposit that applies to many
things at once I just don't know how to
do that and then you know even if we
knew how to model well it's a nice
problem to solve I don't know how to do
it so there is that thanks and sorry for
going over time that's a good question
they're essential reasons that okay and
usually we need to make sure that we
sample each action if you a few times
and somehow it's not easy when you like
how we cannot sample like if initially
like like actions out there is like one
two three we cannot sample action three
like we cannot convince agent to the
attraction three until the sample action
action too and somehow we need to like
jump through hoops to do that and like
the only way we know how is exponential
I I don't know it seems there is some
fundamental reason there but we couldn't
make it into a lower bound